>> NORTH: ...have told to me people have written
too much code that relies on the way we currently
do things. It's almost an opportunity now
that the Google Wave product doesn't need
to--you don't need to worry. It's difficult
for us to make changes because the Google
Wave product is huge, and making changes is
a lot of work, but we're not--you guys have
nothing to worry about that. That is an opportunity
to make the kind of changes that Christian
was talking about. But, you know, some people
have already written a lot of code that works
with Wave as it is now, and I guess it's a
discussion that we all have to have. Can you
guys hear me okay? I know my voice is not
as strong as it might have been on Monday.
Can you hear me at the back?
>> We can hear you bit [INDISTINCT]
>> NORTH: A bit more. Sure.
>> Can you just hold it?
>> NORTH: I don't like holding it. So, I'm
going to give a short overview of A client/server
protocol for Wave. I think--this is--lots
of people have sort of asked about client/server
protocols and want to implement their own
Wave clients all on your phones and other
devices. And so, I'm going to talk about A
client/server protocol for Wave. This is not
the one that's currently implemented, and
I don't think we should stick with the one
that's currently implemented probably because
it's not fully implemented because it was
too tricky. But this is--so this is based
on a design I sent out to the list a few weeks
ago, and there's a few more--a few bits of,
you know, discussion at the end. And
of course, stick your hand up if you have
questions at any point while I'm talking.
Okay. So A client/server protocol, the motivation
is a protocol that allows users to interact
live with Wave. Few many users to interact
live with Wave so they can, you know, type
and see other people's typing live, make formatting
changes, you know, generally you tape the
conversation. And since the live protocol,
the data API provides another live protocol
which means it doesn't sort of receive live
operations. You get snapshots of Waves and
I think--I think that's probably the way we
intend to leave it. All right. There was a
question a while--maybe on Monday about whether
we're going to add live stuff to the data
API. I think the answer is probably no, it
would just turn in to another thing like the
client/server protocol if we did that. So
I think we should have the client/server protocol
for live, and the data API for not live, and
then you--being not live means you can be
much more lightweight. This protocol is quite
heavyweight to implement in a client. Okay,
so I'll be talking about the Wavey bit of
the protocol, the bit that interacts live
with Waves, and some of those other bits that
some client will need to be fully functional;
things like authentication which is just assumed
here, interacting with search, with contact
list, that kind of stuff. Much of that would
be very much more system dependent, not something
that we could standardize on so much. It would
depend a lot on which back ends are talking
to which front ends. Yeah, so I'm sorry, I'm
not going talk about those protocols yet.
Perhaps they are something we can agree later
on. So for history, the Wave in a Box currently
and Google Wave--if you've gone and reverse
engineered our over the wire JSON--implements
of protocol that presents a view of a Wave
multiplexed over a single connection. So when
you open a Wave, you get a bunch of snapshots
down the wire, one per the wavelet. Then you
get a marker that says, "That's it for snapshots,"
although it doesn't really mean too much.
And then for each wavelet that is open, you
can then receive deltas, and so you just tell
which Wavelet they are from the wavelet ID
associated with the delta. And then you could
submit deltas back to those wavelets. And
your view has a channel ID and so when you
submit a delta, you say it's associated with
this view. And then, as a service to you,
the front end that you're talking to drops
your own deltas from the view so you don't
see them echoed back to you. So this was all
implemented--multiplexed over one connection.
The tricky bits are all come to do when we
reconnect, so if your browser connection drops
out, you go offline, something like that.
We tried to have a seamless reconnection when
you come back online. The browser channels
and so on are relatively flaky. They seem
to sort of drop out even on wide connections
periodically, but we didn't want that to sort
of affect you or your data. So when you reconnect,
you used to come back with a big list of known
versions of wavelets. You said, "Look, I saw
this wavelet at your version and then I had
this particular distinction or hash at that
time." And then when you reconnect, the server
will do a bunch of work to try and find a
synchronization point and then restart everything
at that point. So lots of those ideas are
carried over in the new protocol in which
they'll try to do it all over one connection
that made it very complex on the server's
side, and sort of inhibits scalability and
so on. So a client has these sort of four
main requirements they use to discover what
wavelets are in a Wave. If some search says,
"Hey, you have Wave X in your inbox," they
need to discover what wavelets are in that
Wave and be able to, you know, fetch the current
state of them. And then for each of those
wavelets, then you'd be able to stream live
deltas and submit deltas, again, live. So,
we break this sort of protocol into four services.
The server provides and the client can sort
of use them in any order, although there's
an obvious order that makes sense for a simple
web client use case. So, fetching is the first
thing that a client can do. So the client
comes with the Wave ID and says, "Give me
the Wave, what's on this Wave ID," and the
server responds with this list of snapshots
of those wavelets at the current version,
the latest version the server knows. And then
to support reconnection, the client can provide
a list of known wavelet versions saying, "I
saw a--I know that this wavelet is in the
Wave and I last saw that version 10, say.
If you've got the Wave and version 10 is the
latest version, I don't need another snapshot.
I've already got it." So if you've been working
with the Wave live and your connection drops
out, you still have local state. If that local
state is still valid, we don't need to send
you a new snapshot over the wire. So that's
what these known wavelet versions are. And--but
if the wavelet has sort of moved on since
that point, then we'll send you a new snapshot.
Okay, so that's the fetch part. Oh, and then
a way--all of this, by the way, is a--I'm
presenting this as a protocol that's sort
of transport agnostic. I'm not showing you
which bits go over the wire. This is the kind
of protocol that goes over the WebSocket or
the, you know, the Socket.IO library. You
could put it over some other, you know, browser
channel, something else--some other message-based
connected channel.
>> I have a quick question.
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> This is somewhat the question of [INDISTINCT].
Why would--why--you mean there are various
reasons why multiple wavelets inside the Waves
are of sort of connected?
What thing [INDISTINCT] is the reason to have
multiple wavelets [INDISTINCT]?
>> NORTH: So we have two, big use cases for
them that are still pretty valid. One is the
per-user data that we store in the Wave. So
that's a wavelet that's private to each user
who's viewing the Wave. So, an alternative
to that is to store that in some non-Wave
data store somewhere, but using Wave benefits
from reuse of this client-server protocol,
the reconnection, the seamless synchronization
and so on. The other is private replies and
that was kind of the first use case that drove
separate wavelets. So a private reply is a
wavelet with a different participant list.
And so your view might include some private
replies.
>> The Wave in a Box tends to dispose more
private replies?
>> NORTH: Yes. I don't think the--so the protocol
right now doesn't and--but yes, there's nothing
fundamental. It's just a matter of coding,
some more coding for it to support private
replies.
>> [INDISTINCT] providing a different structure,
a semi-structure [INDISTINCT]. The user data
gets stored in the wavelet. Is it going to
be stored the wavelets [INDISTINCT] away?
>> NORTH: I think it would still be stored
in the wavelet. It just wouldn't be a wavelet
that was made of documents. We'd have some
other type of thing that you can have in a
wavelet which was maybe, you know, a native
map, an OT map or something like that. Okay,
so this is a caller response fetch. It's a
one-off, so there's one weakness in this protocol
at the moment and I'm going to sum--sort of
first describing a simple protocol and then
I'll talk about a couple of things that we
can extend to make it better. So this fetch
is just a call and response. And that means
that if a new wavelet shows up in the Wave
at some point while you're viewing it, you
won't find out about it until you do another
request. But later on, we can extend this
to provide a streaming view of snapshots and
the new wavelets, like a private reply, will
show up live. So then, per wavelet, we have
a delta channel. So this is the channel upon
which the client receives the live deltas.
So the request to open a wavelet channel is
simply the wavelet name, wavelet ID, and then
a hashed version that wish to begin the channel.
So if you received a snapshot from your fetch,
your snapshot might be at version 20 and you
want to open the--open the delta channel at
version 20, so the fist delta you get down
the channel applies at version 20. And so
then, the server will sort of scan back through
the deltas it's already received as part of
your--it must be at least of that version
for it to have sent you that snapshot and
resend you anything to help you get up to
date and then be streaming live. So this is
what we call a streaming RPC. So it has one
request and then multiple responses. So the
first response is a channel ID, which is used
to identify the channel for later on when
we're submitting deltas, serving a similar
purpose to the current view protocol and then
future responses are either a delta and/or
a commit notice. So the delta comes down with
all the kind of--it's a bunch of ops and then
a bunch of metadata or about the delta like
the version it's applying at which you can
check as your current version, the author
of the timestamp that reach the server and
so on. A commit notice, it was--so it's piggybacked
on top of this--on top of this response and
that says that some wavelet or a bunch of
wavelets--it might be one wavelet at a time--has
been persistent to discs. So you might be
aware that the Wave server, as deltas are
received and transformed and applied--sorry,
I missed Soren's talk yesterday; this was
probably mentioned--it doesn't write them
to discs right away. Did you go over this?
Yeah. So when they do eventually get written
into disc, this message comes down the client
server protocol to let the client know that
if it's holding any state just so that it
can do a reconnection at some point, this
particular version has hit disc and you can
drop any [INDISTINCT] before that version.
You can always fetch it again from the server.
Okay, so you get one delta channel--the client
will open one delta channel per wavelet. Then
for submitting deltas, the client must submit
a delta against the known server version.
So a known server version is a version the
client knows the server saw. So if you receive
a delta down the delta channel and you don't
have any kind of outstanding submits against
the server, then the delta you receive gives
you a known server version. Or if you receive
a snapshot, then that's a known server version.
So if you imagine, there's multiple clients
all submitting deltas to the server at the
same time, then the server gets them in some
order, but any individual client doesn't know
what order they reach the server and doesn't
know which order its own deltas are going
to leave with those until it receives things
back down the wire from the server. So, mainly,
this prevents the client--the main effect
of this is it prevents the client from submitting
two deltas at a time before receiving an acknowledgement
of the first one. And this--we have this constraint.
This gives us two great advantages. One is
that it massively reduces the resources required
by the Wave server to do OT. If you could
submit arbitrarily many deltas at a time before
waiting for acknowledgement, the server would
need any memory representation per client
of the whole Wave in order for it to be able
to make sense of your second delta after your
first one. But if it's any one at a time,
then the server only needs one in memory representation.
And so that's what we mean by known server
version. It's a state of the wavelet the server
definitely saw. The other is that it auto-throttles
the client server protocol as you're buffering
up local, you know, typing changes waiting
for--waiting for your acknowledgement. So
submitting deltas, you send the wavelet ID
that the delta replies to, the channel ID
that you got from the open delta channel's
first message, and then the actual delta itself.
And in response, I've left all the error responses
out. All of these have, like, a failure response.
But in a successful case, you get the count
of ops applied, which should match the--with
the current RT, that should always match the
number of ops that run the delta that you
sent, the hashed version of the wavelet after
your delta replied, and the timestamp at which
you applied. Okay, now...
>> Does that imply that if you have two plans
to submit deltas on the same Wave, the same
wavelet...
>> NORTH: Yup.
>> ...then that [INDISTINCT] give it to the
clients that the client can submit a delta
against the earlier version or a new version
that's actually the snapshot version itself
on the server?
>> NORTH: In theory, it kind of--yes, a client
can submit against--tend to submit against
an arbitrarily old version and it's the server's
job to transform it up past the entire history.
In practice, we intend to limit the client's
ability to do that. It's a big workload on
the server to develop service opportunity.
So in practice, the Wave server may reject
your delta if it was too old and tell you--tell
you, the client, to do the job of transforming
it up to the current version and try again.
So what was some stuff I missed out? So, all
right, so that's--I mean, as a service to
you, again, when you submit the--on your delta
channel, the server will omit deltas that
it knows are yours. So if you send a bunch
of deltas and some other clients sends a bunch
of deltas, you don't need to receive your
own deltas back because you know what they
look like. The acknowledgement that gives
you this version here tells you when they
applied, so what--how they were interweaved
with other client's deltas. And so, the concurrency
control object inside the client's stack can
here now insert the right--can do transform
which is the right part of it once yours has
been--once you--once the delta's coming down
the stream, catch up with the hashed version
from your acknowledgement, you don't know--no
longer need to transform past that client
delta. Question, yes.
>> Yeah. A question about the kind of op supplies...
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> ...Going back in the response. It seems
like the practice into your [INDISTINCT] with
a number of your--the delta.
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> Is there any intent there that would be
less than the number of the--with the delta?
>> NORTH: So, it's possible for operations
to transform away completely. Let me think.
>> I was thinking more on the case of like
if one of those operations was actually ended
by the server?
>> NORTH: Sorry, the server will accept or
reject the delta in its entirety. So, if anything
does it, fails to apply from a delta, it will
be--the whole thing will be rejected.
>> Back into zero?
>> NORTH: Yeah. It is possible for ops to
transform into nothing and so, it was our
intention that this--and you could have fewer
ops applied than the number that you sent.
In practice, we didn't finish the coding to
have the client appropriately handle that
case. And so, currently, if an op transforms
to nothing, we leave a no op in there which
increments the version number, but has no
effect. So, I guess in future, the count could
be smaller than the number ops that you sent,
but currently, that never happens.
>> I was wondering and sorry, if you get the
response back, just one narrow response, and
you don't supply successfully...
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> ...I was just mentioning [INDISTINCT] client
and I'm not really sure what I do with that
number, I'd probably stir it out. Unlike,
does it really, you know, it seems like to
get rid of the [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Once--so, getting rid of it would
mean removing the possibility of ops transforming
to nothing and I guess we just haven't that
call yet.
>> Well, what can you do with that information?
>> NORTH: So, the concurrency control object
inside the--excuse me, inside the client's
stack is keeping track of the version number
of various things like where are the outgoing
op was intended to apply, where it ends up
applying, and where we're up to in the incoming
delta stream. And so, that version number
is a count of ops and so it needs to know
if an ops are going to--if--sorry. Delta's
going to come--start coming down the stream
with your number that doesn't line up to where
we think a delta boundary is, it's going to
freak out. So, it needs to know where delta
boundaries are, you know, how many ops were
in each delta. Probably the best--probably
an appropriate case will just be to drop that
number and--but that will be giving up on
the transforming of ops, a waste and I think
I'm not sure--it's something to think about.
Okay. So, all right, let's move on. A couple
of other things. So, wavelet creation my--the
designer posted a few weeks ago had a wavelet
creation call, that's not what Google Wave
does. And that sort of flip flop back to thinking
we should get rid the explicit wavelet creation
again. So, wavelet creation then becomes implicit,
you just submit a delta at version zero and
whoever gets the first delta on a wavelet
owns it. There's just a couple of downsides.
One is that we need a bunch of policing of
deltas in the server, so certain wavelets
are sort of--have well-known names, at least
in our current protocols. So for example,
you use it on a wavelet has a well-known Wave,
your client knows how to create it and knows
where to expect it to store your--place a
red state. And so, your client expects to
be able to create this Wave if it doesn't
exist. So therefore, the server mustn't let
any other client create that wavelet maliciously
or accidentally on your behalf because then
you wouldn't be a participant on it and you
couldn't store any per-user data. So, there
are few other--it requires this kind of policing
inside the server, which would otherwise,
of course, be policing logic inside a create
wavelet call. It's right in the date--right
in the depths of delta transmission. But in
any case, implicit delta creation is--has
many benefits. Of course, it's very obvious
that the state of a wavelet is entirely defined
by the deltas that apply to it. If there were
some delta creation call; then that would
have some effect on the state of a wavelet
that would not be reflected in just the history
of deltas. So, that's the main reason that
I think the implicit Waves is the way to go.
Add/remove participant, this was not--I can
really address this in the design that I published
and currently, just--when you get to remove
from a delta--from a wavelet then the delta
stream stops sending you messages. We intend
to add and remove messages at delta stream,
so that you can tell when you've been removed.
You don't always get to remove a participant
op when you get removed. It may be that you
were part of some group when groups are implemented
in Wave in a Box. You may have indirect access
to a Wave, say, by being a member of the Wave
protocol group or something. And if you get
removed from the group in whatever systems
implementing that group, then you lose access
to the wavelet, but you won't see a remove
participant op telling you that. So, we need
a "removed" message to tell you that you can
expect to receive no more deltas on the stream.
And then we need to improve the fetch service.
So, an extension to the fetch service is to
be able to ask for older versions of this
snapshot than the current one. And our intent
is that you could--if you've seen a version
of a wavelet, you can always go and request
that version again. We don't--we'd never take
data away from you that you've seen. Unlike--what
happens? I think in docs, you--when you delete
a doc, you can, you know, it's gone for--you
can delete it for everyone. We didn't want
that to happen in Wave. Particularly, you
know, it's in federation. It doesn't really
make sense to be able to delete something
for everyone. So the server should be able
to provide you access with the last version
that you saw. And so, inside, you use it on
a wavelet somewhere. We stashed the last version
of the wavelet that you saw whenever you open
it up and your client. And the fetch servelet
should be able to ask--should be able to answer
a respond--answer a request for an older version
of a wavelet. Now that imposes some load on
the server to be able to answer that and we
haven't implemented it yet. But at some point,
we should be able to--when you do it--when
you do a fetch across a whole Wave, get the
latest snapshots that you were able to see.
And if you open a stream, be able to open
a stream up to the point where you get removed.
That's it. Hopefully, that's been short and
we've go back up the time. Anymore questions
about client/server protocol? So again, this
is sort of a transport agnostic client/server
protocol for interacting with live Waves.
It's probably something that we can standardize
on, you know, modularly some details so that
everyone's clients can talk to everyone's
servers in this way. It's ignoring some aspects
of it like authentication and sort of the
non-Wavey bits of the protocol. But otherwise,
it's something I hope to be implementing in
the next month or so inside Wave in a Box
so that we can make sure that it works.
>> In the--is the participant list maintained
using OT transports or is it basically just
straightforward OT data?
>> NORTH: Yeah, the participant list, I guess,
is an example of us not using document operations
to do OT. So it has its own OT, which is fairly
simple. Anthony?
>> ANTHONY: Do you still have to specify the
inversion? Can you--what was the history of
this [INDISTINCT] systems for that was [INDISTINCT]
awful, but [INDISTINCT] for the client only
had the inversions from what they saw last,
because if you're not online, you urge user
object wasn't created and so when you update
it--the last version you saw. So basically,
I came home and the clients did different
changes whether they were all [INDISTINCT]
server.
>> NORTH: Yeah.
>> ANTHONY: It didn't get the--it had to actually
make the change before you get all the history.
And so, I was--I asked, in fact [INDISTINCT]
the answer was why you had to specify his
version as opposed to saying, "Just give everything
from his version," when you do it from open
[INDISTINCT].
>> Are you talking about client server call?
>> ANTHONY: Yeah, client server time and that's
what basically--I mean, [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: It
doesn't ring a bell to me.
>> [INDISTINCT] request the federation. If
you request the federation [INDISTINCT] member
was to open request, you know, the old non-wave--WebSockets
protocol [INDISTINCT]. And when you get it
open, you test by a wavelet [INDISTINCT].
>> It's pretty sure the first [INDISTINCT]
I there's a [INDISTINCT].
>> I think we should [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Let's talk about it during the break.
>> I was saying that a...
>> NORTH: That's a bit [INDISTINCT]. I must
be dead.
>> Good morning.
>> Oh, hi, Stan. Yeah.
>> The federation protocol tends to request
or require him [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Okay. Sorry. Any other questions,
otherwise it's--is it break time or is there
another talk?
>> No, we've got discussion on Wave.
>> NORTH: Yes, adapted on the way of government
thinks. Right, excellent.
>> Index Waves gone away?
>> NORTH: Not yet, but I'm really trying hard
to make them go away.
aying that a...
>> NORTH: That's a bit [INDISTINCT]. I must
be dead.
>> Good morning.
>> Oh, hi, Stan. Yeah.
>> The federation protocol tends to request
or require him [INDISTINCT].
>> NORTH: Okay. Sorry. Any other question